this is lemonhope part 2 how am I
supposed to think about it so he comes
across I will say this I shall never I
forgot it
yeah I'm just about to say I will never
forget this flannel boxing day yes I
think so okay I actually got it yes you
know rattleballs fibre flannel Boxing
Day no because it was so strange I had
to repeat it in my head a couple times
to make sure I heard it right and then
we said it again like yeah that was in
flannel boxing day so it's weird but if
you told me like my name's Joey like
I'll forget as I sew across this guy who
won't forget what it comes across this
guy in the cloud
again very Mario Brothers yeah I keep
mine to see it throw those spiky things
- yes yes so it comes down and since
I've been watching you and they'll serve
take care you you won't be my apprentice
I kill these whale things that you know
eat a whole bunch of treasures and stuff
and then I keep the treasures and so he
says yes and goes on board and they're
flying around but he keeps having these
dreams those really surreal black
background dreams and the ass why and
flannel says as Franco's you're feeling
bad you should go back and help them if
you know you might get rid of the dream
so he agrees goes back he defeats uh
Lemongrab defeats him with the music and
the place is free and finally bubblegum
offers him a chance to come back to the
kingdom and I forget to ruler just be in
it just be the champion yeah dude just
to be the champion and goes no I just
kind of came back so I'd stop thinking
about you guys I guess I'll come back
when I start thinking about you again
you know might be a thousand years or so
later peace and walks out yeah pretty
much just a big anti joke or a joke
that's building up to one thing gives
you something else but then we cut to
presumably a thousand years later just
sometime in the future and he goes back
to
room and he goes to sleep um I'll say
this I even though it might be misplace
or maybe not I don't know I like the
tone actually it's a whole bit with like
the dreams and the and the song at the
end and cutting two years later and him
going back I'm saying like there's there
is something strong in here but it's not
it's not fully realized that's like it's
in there somewhere you know sort of like
the atmosphere and all that was heavy
but it's still lemonhope it's still not
that interesting a character um and I
don't know if they could you know if
they did the same story with say Flame
Princess this would be heartbreaking
like that ending I would just feel like
oh like oh my god it wasn't just for a
reason like I'll just come back whatever
uh you know it'd be some other reason
why she had to leave and come back when
she's ready or so uh she feels she's
ready something along those lines um so
it's like on the one hand I I admire
elements of it you know that there's
good setups in there but yeah I I think
because it's lemon hoping it's just not
as strong a story I don't feel it
totally paid off but I'm still glad I
saw some of that stuff cuz I guess I did
sort of dig the kind of different tone
that it was going there and I bet your
time could get really dark yeah um but I
will say this also that made me realize
cuz you know we always say I can't
believe there's these are 11 minutes you
know and with these last two I say to
myself boy it feels like it's 11 minutes
in like kind of the worst way because
you feel like boy they tried to cram a
lot into it and everything's kind of
backwards in front well this this was
supposed to feel like this if we had
more time or if we did this different or
whatever and it didn't make me
appreciate even more how much they do
fit in and how much it is emotionally
satisfying majority of the time yeah um
because yeah because I was watching it's
like I'm saying this should hit me like
the pacing of this you know like
especially the ending was
as you know pretty adult but it just was
not the right character and possibly not
even the right story so yeah again
that's sorry my same fellow the first
one I guess just very very mixed no this
is not some strange leaving I enjoyed
the dream sequences I actually that's
about the only thing I enjoyed about it
I had this one was boring to me and I
think part of it is because I really
can't stand lemonhope that I just don't
care so if I don't care my mind wanders
because I just I don't care I hear you a
lot when you say maybe if it was a
different character this could be so
much more I I agree with you a hundred
percent I think that's what they were
going for but for whatever reason
lemonhope isn't doing it for me it's not
doing it for you
that whole singing thing I mean it was
okay and it probably means so much more
but I think the issue for me personally
is that I just don't like it and I've
checked out like halfway through so by
the time we get to this song and it was
like oh do it
no nevermind and it's like she finally
sings and it's like oh god yes okay
you're doing you're just ready to call
it easy and go bakit it didn't feel like
11 minutes it felt like forever for me
it really did and then the song dragged
for me and and it and I think a lot of
it has to do with I just don't like
lemonhope and they don't care in the
song this whole episode is whatever I
feel like this was a two-parter what the
hell yeah I was kind of thinking that
too like really this is what we devoted
an update to pardon you
from that season finale with fins arm
being removed the alternate dimension
stupidly at least the first half of that
was like whoa what's going on in the
second half right and it's like this
point it's like I start went in and left
yeah they even even with that that
second part which you didn't like very
much it still you could I don't know I
just felt more complete it felt like it
it had this great big purpose right now
there may be a purpose I see no purpose
other than to introduce an annoying
effing character I don't know I hope we
never see him but I feel like we're
gonna see him I feel like this was the
big reveal to say haha here's a new
character it looks very much like you
know like he's dead and gone at the end
I didn't like they gave him his ending
well that's a step up like he left and
he does not come back until that point I
think no they created a character they
didn't know what the hell to do with so
they had to kind of come up with some
way to close it out again if I like
another closing or something I was just
thinking that the past couple have felt
like these like they're trying to be
these really big uh like you said
closing narratives for some of these
characters and it's like yeah did they
think this was like the last season or
no I don't think it was that because as
I found out thanks to the guys on the
forum or on the comment section like no
right after the season ended this next
season opened like they they keep going
so they they knew but I think it was
more along the lines of okay we're done
with Flame Princess and Finn we're
closing it out we're not going to deal
with that at least for a while we're
done with lemonhope we're gonna close
that out like I think they were just
kind of closing the door on some
characters that they don't plan on going
back to for a while and so therefore
fans aren't going we'll wait what about
blank but there's so many unanswered
things still in Adventure Time II
honestly I think I would think just
people be used to I mean I'm
there's like a million unanswered things
I'm just like okay yeah no this I
understand it takes this time it'll just
deliver it whenever it wants to and it
will probably be a really funny
punchline or joke or whatever one they
do it but people aren't as patient as
you you have to remember that I don't
think that there's anything wrong with
them closing off you know some of the
doors I just the only thing that bothers
me is that we had to have two episodes
to close this stupid door that no one
even wanted to peek through excuse me
that I never even wanted to bother
peeking through much less leave open so
as far as I'm concerned it was closed
from the beginning why we wasted two
episodes to close lemonhope off was a
waste was a complete waste fire fire
Flame Princess would have been a really
nice you know two-parter they could have
done something with that
I mean Betty for god sakes could have
been yeah I was going to say why don't
you get like one episode with Betty
which felt incredibly cramped and forced
together but we got to dragged out
episodes of lemonhope um
no I actually completely agree actually
that I'm said just with what you just
said there because I like you're now
thinking like how they would slowly fade
into the dreams and fade out so
disturbing I thought God if they had
those dreams or something similar in the
Betty episode and they made it two parts
God that would have been I mean I like I
would have been that I would have been I
mean I like that episode but it's like I
would have been there even more no
actually I mean there's many problems as
I did have with Betty Betty was actually
a very interesting episode and I wish
there was more with Betty but if I like
there's Betty Betty's gone but where
it's like oh here's lemonhope and and
guess what he's there for a thousand
years later it's like you'd be you know
I I don't know I just
lemonhope is a very what I say is an
unlikable character like there's selfish
characters and there's characters who
don't care about what's going on Jake
can be self Jake can be kind of like
whatever I don't really care but the way
he still deals with things the way he
does every
in a while like he'll be like I don't
want to do that but I will because I
really care about Finn you know he has
these emotions like are they showing
that it doesn't matter what happens
lemon people are going to be lemon
people and that no matter how much you
try to like change them or you know
however much they try to change it's not
gonna matter
all they're gonna care about is
themselves I mean I mean he still made
the ideas like you see he does come in
that's years and years later he does
come back I guess that's what they're
trying to say at some point you know
that actual you know sort of jump for
finding the humanity like hey I do care
and I want to find home where I came
from and appreciate again whatever is
there but it's in a character you don't
care about and you don't see any of that
longing or anything um and I don't know
that there's got to be a little bit more
of a balance in there where it's I mean
if you want to like you say Jay can be
very selfish it usually is but there's
still this element of there are things
he cares about you know and we'll
sacrifice and we'll go to you know it's
just finding them out and sort of even
him going through that deduction of
discovering what he really cares about
yeah yeah I feel like it's kind of I
feel like I miss Finn almost too it's
like her a lot of these it's like yeah
it's mainly the side characters um the
last things I want to bring up for one I
felt with this one especially the lack
of time I felt was terrible the last
episode he was pathetic he was all alone
he was a child this episode all of a
sudden he's kind of grown up and now he
wants to help his people
how much time has passed well the
flannel guy says something about the
last you know this is the third time in
the last week or something yeah yeah so
you could kind of get an idea of what
it's been at least 2 to 3 weeks at least
if not months he's had time to gain back
you know yeah I never made the
assumption he's like growing up like
that like but yes but that's my thing
but instantaneously in about a month all
of a sudden he
he grows up yeah a month beforehand he
was knocking things over saying I don't
really care I'm gonna do whatever the
hell I want to and all of a sudden to do
I want to go help my people
I don't think that's the case at all I
don't think he wanted to help the people
to help them oh okay he did that for his
own selfish reasons I can't stop having
these stupid nightmares while you're
having your nightmares because your
subconscious is telling you that you owe
these people something how do I make it
stop
help them okay I'm helping them because
I don't want nightmares anymore he's not
helping them because he feels better he
wants to help them he's helping them
because he wants his nightmares to go
away so I don't feel like he grew up at
all well I'll see if you're gonna go so
dark
yeah dark is fine I mean but you're
gonna go so dark you have to have some
yeah um you have to have the emotion to
balance it out our character who is
emotional enough for Carrie enough to
balance it out because when you have
that ending where they say would you
like to be here and then be our champion
he goes nope and it's pretty much just a
joke it's a joke you know it's well I
really thought he was gonna say yes
they're explaining the joke yeah but
then we're gonna have the serious ending
right after I'm like you can't do that
you have to sort of pick one that you're
mostly going to be and it was trying to
do both a lot of times Adventure Time
can do that can do it very well but
that's because if the core there's
somebody that you care about even the
wallet that ice monster and the little
yeah her dog is it they never spoke but
by god I want to know what was gonna
happen to them you know I mean it's
establishing that connection I think
there was nothing to connect with yeah
you know they're trying to stay they're
trying to tell like pretty much the
story of Moses without identifying with
Moses at all just replacing him with
this jerk he's just a jerk who cares
about nothing and it's like that story
would not be as impressive if just the
whole thing let my people go why I just
don't want to think about it's not
really is
nightmares yeah it's just not as big a
story um yeah you know and I think
that's look if it would have ended with
him being like family they'll come back
in a thousand years
piece I'd be like okay like I would've
actually given me a chuckle that would
have made me laugh but you're right it
goes right into the whole kind of song
thing and it's like okay this is fine
okay with this but that was kind of
unbalanced yeah it's like I would have
loved that the ending of another episode
it felt like that song to me felt like
the blooper reel like the deleted scenes
like the fanfiction written right after
I've seen that I disagree with that but
what I did like for one for some reason
the Sun reminded me of Jill Sol Byul I
don't know the way the way you so feel
the way she was singing like the voice
it sounded like it but okay you're gonna
have to re-watch it Doug cuz you
probably didn't catch it
did you catch Finn and Jake's tree the
tree not that giant tree that was
spinning Jake's tree and if you look at
one of the branches their spins backpack
that that is the one thing I was
guessing - it was cool just seeing the
future it's like that's kind of the end
and it was bittersweet because it's it's
grand and big but it's also kind of gray
well yeah but there's Finn and Jake's
tree Maxted towering into the sky Candy
Kingdom was also there that city he was
going through what's the candy cane I
was gonna say yeah that's why else again
that like I sort of as symptoms candy
cane because I saw the candy cane fence
and stuff but at the same time it's like
yeah it's interesting cuz it is
bittersweet cuz it's still really big
and it sort of turned into like a
modern-day city but it's just so
colorless yeah and that alone was so
much more intriguing than any of the art
that lemon grant was going through it's
like I just love to know like you know
just wow what is gonna happen yeah like
I didn't catch and so funny I thought
that that tree was spinning Jason the
Contra little tiny backpack but I didn't
catch in the background or the city is
the actual old Candy Kingdom Jim was
what he pointed that out to me
he's like hey I'm like oh dumb an idiot
but I like seeing the future of what is
going to be coming it looks like the war
happened because there's a bunch of
planes crashed with the three-piece it's
three pieces of candy corn so it looks
like another war happens
yeah and I'm so curious about that and I
could care less about Lemongrab yeah I
mean that that is what Lemongrab sorry
lemonhope yeah I keep gaming stuff
they're essentially the same annoyance
but my other question before I'm done
how do they eat who well okay how long
does he had his brother in his stomach
he's yet to digest him
so how can I be her thing how can you
erase something from his brain with an
eraser it's lights let's try the new
please don't be yet your do not get up
do not be late to your room you like it
do not grab the eraser do not point that
gun at me